I want to apply this on neither of us
especially me doing a Cosby impression
this whole time cuz we're over that or
over it you know Obama's president ma'am
now I want to do an Obama inbred out
I would actually like to see you doing
no bottom in the first doctor dr. Cosby
you could have done both I asked for the
Obama that's yeah but you did are just
people saying their own names become Jon
Stewart he does that
Oh someone's a little eerie I'm
terrified of holding a baby get over it
I will hold a stranger's baby while I go
over the log flume [__] quick question
once you give me the baby
by animal law that's my baby which is
the truest thing I've ever heard before
that's very true if a bear another bear
the baby does I hold this really quick
that other baby will run off into the
wilderness with that baby because that
is now that Bears baby now it's mine you
just gave your baby
there's no paternal testing for bear
yeah I have the baby yes this is my baby
run this is my baby Dale run
it's a sad pitiful if a beer got its
baby so there's no one to call this no
you can't think about it yeah a beer
dude do you bear President Obama how
close would be one time I was in a cabin
and I heard some rustling I got up and I
looked out the window and there was a
bear just in owning my garbage really
yeah yeah it was really tearing it up
hey let me ask you a question yeah we
doing a net cabin just learning about
myself I like to think Jesus has a great
sense of you oh yeah moonwalk among the
clouds in Birken to Don's lungs if you
were Jesus you've been around since all
of time mm-hmm you got a good noodle you
really just want to take things from the
early ate all the time but that was his
period yeah yeah no see
cool however however MJ MJ let me tell
you about that guy that kid hats down
I do a good MJ doing them too Jerrod
thank you so much for taking the time to
talk thank you thank you very much for
having getting me down
[Music]